people in the uk could be offered a
third dose of the coronavirus vaccine
from september and they're not alone the
u.s plans to follow suit and israel's
booster rollout is well underway
booster vaccines are given to literally
boost protection against viruses and
diseases all vaccines
when you give them to people over time
do have a reduction
in ineffectiveness this is the same for
every vaccine
if you grew up in the uk you would
likely have had one age three and again
aged 14.
[Music]
experts have found that protection from
covid in those double jabbed with pfizer
or az begins to wane within six months
the average seems to drop about three
percent a month our reasonable
pessimistic guess is that by the end of
the year
these percentage protections will be
down to about 50 percent
research suggests effectiveness in the
pfizer vaccine after one month was 88
after five to six months this dropped to
74
in the astrazeneca vaccine effectiveness
after one month was 77
this dropped to 67 percent after four to
five months the uk's vaccine rollout
prioritized the vulnerable and
healthcare workers so by winter 2021
their protection against covid could
fall to below 50
in a reasonable worst-case scenario if
our aim is to reduce the number of
deaths and hospitalizations then booster
jabs are definitely
what we should be prioritizing the uk
government is preparing to roll out
boosters from september 2021. the joint
committee on vaccination and
immunization has recommended they be
administered with flu jabs for ease and
increased uptake
thousands of vulnerable brits are
expected to be offered a booster and
much like the initial vaccine rollout
groups of priority will be determined by
the jcvi
israel began rolling out third jabs at
the end of july for those over 60. since
the middle of august those over 40 have
been eligible as well as pregnant women
teachers and healthcare workers under
40. i think it's very important to get
the vaccine i'm a teacher
i don't want to
get sick and
i'm going to school next week i want to
be prepared initial results showed a
third jab for those over 60 offered five
to six times greater protection against
serious illness and hospitalization from
10 days after the jab
germany canada and france have also
announced booster campaigns and booster
shots will be available in the us from
the 20th of september you know this will
boost your immune response
will increase your protection from covet
19.
vaccines can be designed specifically to
target variants of concern there's
currently no variant specific boosters
they're effectively just a third dose
but there could be in the future
while some experts say urgent plans are
needed for vaccine boosters not everyone
agrees doubleh is calling for a
moratorium
on boosters
until at least the end of september in
some countries vaccination rates remain
as low as one or two percent of the
population
experts including the director of the
world health organization warned that
stronger variants could develop if
vaccination rates aren't raised globally
[Music]
the data shows that vaccines work
against covid with countless
hospitalizations and infections
prevented and tens of thousands of lives
saved
experts say waning protection is to be
expected and is not a reason not to get
vaccinated the vaccines are currently
protecting people against severe disease
and death from kobit 19 and if people
haven't had their vaccine please come
forward and get your vacancy
you